hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play limbo I got a head like just
a little bit of myself there's a little
there was electrical part from the end
of that thing I just had to pull it and
push it and jump on it and get up there
I didn't realize I wasn't recording so
whoops oops on my part pooch funk oh
it's dark the world is spinning that's
another rock I see that that is that is
another rock I see it right there it's
right there right there
hey tricare hate right dere right dere
Oh wouldn't this be creepy it's like a
big perv ah no oh no oh no don't crush
me with the rock don't crush me on the
rock yuck okay
don't do that junk anyway oh yeah haze
wouldn't it be like terrifying as a
giant pair of eyes just poofed out of
the darkness creepy zone
okay now that that troll moment is over
troll Rock I'd roll you now I wait here
so I can jump on that ladder
but to put your job yeah yeah okay oh oh
you son of a [ __ ] how dare you
Oh Oh No no box ah box oh thank you box
Thank You box with a box break in the
lectures or was I supposed to go up
there wait here
oh I don't think it good out there
without touching it so let's go down
here box I bear shoe box don't be like
that box
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh we are
come here buck come on ah screw you den
crew your box I don't need you I go on
without you I go forward without you
Boing Boing Boing a laser what the hell
kind of post-apocalyptic nightmare is
this where they have lasers I need the
box uh no I couldn't have gotten the box
here anyway aah aah
ed what is bullet it lots of bullet Raja
Bullett nice boot come here ok lots of
bullets ah that's a lot of bullets ah ah
ah ah ah
ah trying to find me thing Geyer got
here boy I picked you up ah I gotcha I
gotcha
I got it I got it come back here
Cabrillo it's moving anyway come back
here come here come here
break it it's Logan ha ha ha nope oh
yeah yeah there we go here we go
knocking before me
huh huh
don't shoot me bro I'll get a bogey
double get a bug in a bug boy but
seriously that's some that's a pretty
advanced technology for this no matter
buying a boy
nope okay never mind then all right
electrified rectified ah okay no button
big whoa
cool can I jump a backrub um okay no
seriously what kind of what God plays is
this it has this kind of technology oh
thank you oh I almost had you come here
babe yeah I like that tire swing in the
background whap
okay maybe I got to stack him up so that
I can get back up beep ah yeah oh so
great
wait that doesn't help me at all wait I
could have gotten up with one
maybe if I stack both of them on top of
each other and upward uh booze I didn't
do anything okay what the hell I need to
get one of these boxes up here for that
ladder over there I need to be able to I
need to be able to there's always so
much of any incline okay I got this I'm
I'm kind of smart there's always so much
of that incline they can go up so if I
get a box up there and then I get up
there then I can do all there's a flat
part here hang on I got this the flat
part here so if I get on this and I jump
up when this one falls down before that
one falls down I'll be able to jump over
and get up out there okay
Bing oh yeah up there girl
oh yeah son of a monkey okay take to
boot now let's actually remember how to
climb up on a box because that's a
useful life skill in life come on come
up guy you son of a [ __ ]
Oh something went wrong with you went
wrong with you what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you Siri you can't
climb up on a box it's really that
difficult for you I dare you odd oh damn
it not enough time
okay so if we if we put a box on the
button fit up there damn it
okay that's sliding down there oh wait
no it's right here the incline ah that's
it that's totes it man that I jump on
the box and I ride it up with it ah
genius genius genius make sure it is off
the flat part oh yeah what's this Oh
what's easily move here we go boom yeah
ah ah come on
that's hardly fair whatever I was on the
run oh wait no I just push it up against
here tonight
ah I know I know I know I know I know I
know I know I know I know I got this I
got it I got it okay the box is there
and I push I push you over a clam on you
know pull myself up and I'm up here and
it goes up and over me I'm so smart
oh he's totes it man don't kill me
please don't kill me ah yes yes I got it
yeah oh yeah oh yeah Bing Bing Bing Bing
Oh Oh Bing Oh Bing say with me Bing Bing
Bing say hey Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing ah
yes
oh okay wait wait a minute wait wait a
minute that's not fair what the hell
what what did what the hell well what
what what what why why I'm confused
why
ah I wouldn't get up there oh oh oh hang
on sister a little bit off I need oh oh
oh I told I totes got it man
oh you guys I got it I got it I got it I
got it everybody I have it so when that
comes up there and then I put that there
and then I move that up there see I
gotta get this up here tell the DA I
bear she up the hill I climb on you a
jumper for you I get up here and when
you go off I get up here and then on the
button and then I have time
yeah just Paulie yeah get it get it ha
ha ha ha hey ha don't kill me all right
yeah yeah oh yeah neckla I'm up there I
jump I jump off I jump out for bait
can I just jump on that let do I need do
any do I just jump up there yes I can I
don't need the box I can push the box
all the way up and then when it rises I
rise with this is when I climb on the
Box this is when I climb at the but oh
yeah you bun you mm that yeah I yump on
you did we get up here
and ha ha ha ok me got the box okay I
guess not okay
ah Oh Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing I
got it I didn't know that was a do part
puzzle but I got it Oh in a record time
oh oh yeah okay now [ __ ]
Bing seems straightforward oh it's
another puzzle I guess I should you know
be kind of expecting puzzles to show up
ah huh okay not gonna make that ah I got
it
a dildo ping then I boom and go up and
trigger the machine gun up now oh hello
mister but you got or knuckle give me 50
bucks a fish a fish the box a bit the
box over here and then I jump on it are
you up on you I clam up you or miss me
mister machine gun ha whoa whoa wonder
ki heck yup on you I okay a dumb button
and jump now okay that nah that no work
I barely you maybe I need like another
box to get up there but I don't have
another box oily crap other things are
falling upwards now holy crap this is
awkward it's like super awkward but I
got it I got it
excuse me perdón me wait okay um
oh no I'm gonna be stuck forever oh
we're going back into the woods oh okay
um going back into the woods but this I
never I only have this one box I'm gonna
use this box to get up there and up
there
holy my brain
ah okay this is it's too tall to get up
so I need the box down there first to
get up there and then I need the box up
there to get up there one more
and it goes in so far that it knock off
the box that I have that I have has it
in it have as it hasn't in it has it it
did they did give me point turn another
box I don't think there's another box
it's there Oh No okay so I need like ah
then I need another box up here to get
dad yeah
oh my brain can explode Oh No okay um
all right I can get this I got this guys
I got it I got it I got it
do I need another but I don't think I
saw another box for okay that set up
dere but I can't I have to be over you
to press that button so I can't be like
over there
what da [ __ ] I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know I'm
gonna go back down maybe I can get that
box from Down Yonder way and get that
Todd Toto bring that up to here bring
that up yon winged away don't you me OOP
okay there was another box I know there
was but it's odd oh no I can't get it I
can't get to it
oh crap so I got to solve this all by
myself
maybe there's something down there beep
your uh u s-- nerve
yeah that's whoa whoa ah I see it that's
it ah [ __ ]
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
giving you gimme oh yeah super secret Oh
super secret super secret super secret
I don't blink got it yeah underground
achievement unlocked yeah I get it I get
it
well that didn't get me farther in the
game but I did it okay so there must be
something over that yonder way oh you
didn't even give me okay anyway I ran
out of time but thank you all so much
for watching I'll figure this puzzle ah
thanks again for watching and as always
I will see you in the next part
bye bye